hitachi produces a shocking amount of
stuff from brain scanners right on up to
nuclear reactors this being Japan it's
also in the robot game I've gone to one
of the company's vaunted research labs
to see its latest take on the robot that
people desire most an autonomous helper
Hitachi calls this creature EMU
I am you okay Nene was developed as a
sort of friendly robot concierge
equipped with AI for navigation and
speech recognition he might provide
directions at an airport or do some
low-level security work or he might be
kicked over by a cynical reporter
looking for a good time that's pretty
cool that resemblance between EMU and
the adorable Hello Kitty is on purpose
EMU's designer hace baba wanted the
robot to have the same harmless
non-creepy feel is it meant to look like
a child yes because everyone liked
there's an adorable quality to these
robots and they may be helpful one day
for the moment though rolling around
looking cute is about the extent of what
they can do and they're super expensive
to make you have a price that you're
aiming to get to we even polite to you
know keep a sound come be cheaper than a
car come okay
what's that emu you want to make up for
your failings by showing me an
autonomous vehicle okay
thank CPU here's my rad this sweet hog
with the flip top door is called r opus
the way we go
it's sort of like a self-driving car but
is meant to travel down sidewalks
instead of on the road
and this is the vehicles inventor rio
key hits a nosy nosy cocky does a nice
identification review and yesterday you
need to go to mistake masticatory it's
caliber 13 a it's demo course on
supernovas knowing every touch there
your mother motivated laugh Japan's
aging population has forced the country
to try and invent new ways to help
seniors make their way around cities the
idea here is that someone can summon the
car to their house and then go for a
leisurely drive to the store the open
windows and slow speed of rope it's
means that the driver can even have a
chat with a friend for perhaps a minute
walking nearby
it's a beautiful utopian future Itachi
is imagining for us all full of smart
compassionate robots attending to our
every need but suffice it to say that
future very much remains the future
you